before we jump into the fighter and the
kids that skid with a z
boise we just went live and get tickets
right now boise one night only to me
cold ass night so let's snuggle up
let's have some laughs me and my homies
will be there boise idaho
december 5th one night only uh it's at a
theater in boise idaho those tickets
just went on sale right now tfatkay.com
uh other than that phoenix is november
5th through the 7th
nashville november 19th to 21st then
boise december 5th
let's ride y'all t5k.com for tickets
but while you're listening to this
podcast or you're watching this podcast
you got to stop what you're doing don't
turn the show off but
go to onit.com fighter 10 off the best
supplements on the goddamn planet listen
i'm sick of telling you guys how good
their supplements are i'm sick of
telling you how good their fitness
equipment is
go to onit.com try it out for yourself
save ten percent
on it.com fighter you get kettlebells
you got honest extreme and fitness for
your thick ass
we got battle ropes we got steel maces
we got sandbags
lose weight me and chappelle's thick ass
we some bbms we're going to lose weight
with the help of
on it we got protein powders we got keto
stuff
we got mct oil we got elk bars warrior
bars
protein powder like i told you earth
grown nutrients my favorite coffee on
the planet
it's [ __ ] yeah coffee black rifle onyx
collab
favorite coffee that caffeinated
crystals in that [ __ ] go to onit.com
fighter 10 off frickin try it on it.com
fighter it probably knows your car they
see they see [ __ ]
no payments no payments uh things paid
off yeah
she gave she let us when i'm good she
give me allowance and she uh let me ride
um
she so you could take chappelle in my
other car oh yeah
yeah and then so he gives you a right
yeah yeah so you're not moving around
anymore i mean i uber to her house
but it's like what it's so close it's so
close yeah it's like a seven dollar uber
ride
cat how you feeling they let you back in
the uh
yeah i just deposit for antibodies yup
i feel great um corporate like
the afternoon of monday i started
getting comments like r.i.p
cat and i was so confused
after the third one i texted you i was
like did you tell me i was like i told
you
you test positive for antibodies and
then
i put dot dot and then you also died
hey look i was telling about a comment i
got well i saw she was there was like rp
cat
i hope the feet is doing okay but
it's so unique it's so like huge unique
yeah because they're very big what's
nice
for an asian though huh oh yeah for an
asian okay yeah that's true
yeah and they kind of look big and long
what size are you
13 is tricky man if your sneaker had 13
is tricky
they don't really matter like a lot a
lot of 13 so the prices are always high
you know what i tried to do today i
tried to i went online i went to
nike.com
and i tried and i tried to find some
kids why don't you call me huh
why uh what are you looking for i was
just looking for some shoes because you
guys keep
you know that
dog with the white socks my socks are
ripped
you got you got yeah
he dressed like he been on the yard
you got a hole in the house oh sh
yo got chappelle you're not gonna find
any [ __ ] shoes that i liked i was
like these are all
really bad looking well for your like i
feel like a dunk would be dope for you
like your nike dog would be sick
like an old school jordan one would be
dope for you is that
like a high top shoe uh just like mid
what do you think what do you like
like low top or mid i mean i've been
rocking vans since
that so i'd be low time i'm telling you
dunks are the way to go i'll send you
some options
okay i tried and i was like and you want
like a black shoe
yeah i only wear black shoes black shoes
yeah
but i do want those uh i'm trying to
find the uh kung fu kinnies
the uh kendrick lamar's oh yeah the
adidas collab
no uh oh yeah yeah
yeah hold on the not the red ones what
color
the black ones those like right there
i've been trying to find those oh those
look nice
that's what i thought it was hard that
would be dope
right that's fine yeah yeah i'll
dope for you cool i never wear red my
favorite color is blue
one of these uh those but like those
you see those black and white ones for
you
this one right now those are no yeah the
low tops yeah
oh those are nice those are dope right
skateboarding shoes
sb dunk sb skateboard i know you liked
them because your voice got high
i know i don't know if anybody would
call that out
but you but you you want you want you
want low tops though
so i know he was like really feeling
them i was like yeah he really was yeah
yeah i know yeah it was it was tough but
i mean [ __ ] it chin did you
did you test for the antibodies too or
no no i didn't
weird it's good but but that'll make
sense because he had covert i had code i
didn't test no i didn't test
i i just walked around oh type move
because i got tested so many times
remember when i went to mike tyson's
ranch to do the
engineering they tested me there i've
always did do engineering
they tested you there testing me there
like the deep nasal swap too yeah that's
a negative so i know i have the
antibodies yeah yeah
that nasal want to get you though oh it
sucks my nose is bleeding afterwards
yeah it's a good leg
yeah they
some just go around the like a few times
and then some get my girl yeah
yeah one the dude that did mine he was
freaking i was like they're rich for
your brain
basically yeah i'm like at least buy me
a drink first yeah if you're gonna get
up in here and the dude
i don't know how long did they do it
like have it in there because the dude
was gonna count
they count to like five oh he was
counting real slow yeah they like
rotated like one yeah two three
just chin got a i got around it
obviously i get tested mtv they got cat
sitting home yeah yeah how you feeling
today's all good good
yeah i think it was from that time you
guys got just asymptomatic you're like
i'm
fine she felt something though well i
didn't fuel on i thought i had covid but
then when the test came back negative i
just assumed it was like terrible period
when we all had it pains yeah
i tested negative the first time too and
then i took a test the day after that
was positive
yeah that's all yes that's weird you are
the father
you are the father it's all a bunch of
[ __ ] a little test she had us do was
look like a little pregnancy test yeah
bruh i thought i was like hold on
they did the real deal here showtime did
with the blood yeah yeah
i'm scared malik was being such a little
baby
with the prick yeah because he looked at
it and he started freaking out like is
that a thumbtack that was a long-ass
needle yeah
it was a long name no one likes it that
was yeah no one liked that no bro
hell no because i'm scared of needles
the flu shot i don't know i don't think
i had that yet you need a flu shot
well my everybody have the flu nah i
never had the flu
what no i don't feel really flu shots
these days well my mom has never gotten
a flu shot
i don't think i don't think i've known a
person to give the flu shot older people
get it my parents get it oh okay that's
what i'm saying my mom just got it
because if you get the flu shot and you
have potential to get corona
or ip okay what's tough is though if
you're older you get a flu shot and then
you get the flu really bad like some
people when they get the shots because
the sh what the shot is it's a small
dose of the
flu the virus yeah so your body oh
there's a big immunity to it but
they're putting flu into your body oh
you see a lot of people get sick as [ __ ]
from it
why would i want to get a shot by that
that's what some people do yeah
hey you got your queen's hair on you
better be a queen's hair i know i hope
so i got you you got it i see you
she has blonde hair yeah oh she's red
head yeah she uh she's she's redheaded
no no she's
she's a that was red that was not just
kids
she watched this episode
that's not red i'm scared
don't mess this up i don't have anywhere
to go after this yeah
come on now i'm gonna sleep at the
studio i'll tell you what i think i
[ __ ] up
send the family to montana on friday i
looked at the weather it's
negative for them what you'll still be
able to do [ __ ]
yes is that negative for the high uh
that was at night this was snow
friday and saturday which they say it's
nice when it snows it's beautiful
i left denver because of the snow i
[ __ ] hate this
oh you don't like this you grew up in
that [ __ ] i hate it
i hate it really hate snow you'll be a
big ass snow angel it's just um
it's just a beast has tiger been to the
snow yet
yeah he went to chicago and then went to
like this winter wonderland thing in san
diego so
in san diego so fake snow oh just does
he like it yeah but i mean he doesn't
have
like it's gonna have to live it's
different when you have to be it like
in it yeah you know what i'm saying you
don't take them back home to the folks
and stuff
that's rare i go back home let's go back
there if i do the comedy works in denver
oh shut up that's it shout out yeah
that's it damn so you really hate the
snow i hate the snow hate cold
so what you gonna do in boise we'll see
you made that voice i don't know we'll
see i know
yo i forgot to tell y'all there was a
throuple
at a throuple at my show in tampa it's a
thrill
that's that's a three-person love
triangle
so you're personally like they're in a
relationship
yeah like a couple of throuple though
yeah
i would just call that an open
relationship oh it's one person
no they're all they all like each other
there's one dude two chicks
yes hell yeah have you ever seen it the
other way oh yeah
two dudes one chick yes i think that's a
pansexual right no
oh yeah you've seen it i have a friend
who does that
really yeah he shares queen they're all
in a relationship yeah they live
together like
and have kids oh my god like i like you
i like you i like you
yeah man figure it out two dudes one
girl yep
i've never seen it though good for her
but uh but this is great for her this
three
this couple that you saw were they
attractive
and it's so cool is it not so cool
i was on stage and i saw the i saw the
three sitting there
thorpe yeah i saw the throat was sitting
there and the dude
uh uh all of a sudden like the two girls
just like re reach across the the table
and just start making out
hardcore while like while i'm in the
middle of my set
so they were like [ __ ] this show let's
be real but they were
they came up to me they were so nice
they were really really nice you know
how they
actually really liked it yeah so they
were making out there in the middle of
the show
you know i and i didn't want to call it
doing your main punch like
i was about to say
no they actually weren't even like that
it wasn't even like like oh this is our
sexual thing that we do they actually
genuinely
were just all through a couple yeah
that's not going to work out but sure
how do you know that
name one person that's worked out for do
you wear out david oh yeah
ray davis who's d-ray davis i know d-ray
but he has two girlfriends yes and they
live together
there's a whole thing they they live
together happy relationships sister
wives
happy sister wives they do that all the
time i'll tell you right now but do the
girls like each other
i'll tell you i'll tell you right now
that's what i'm saying like yeah sure no
sure
yep sure favorite thing yep sure here's
the thing
it's a nightmare at home guarantee it
how you figured it out i wonder what the
you know what because you know what i
had a hurry that's my question
i wonder what like yeah what if you know
two of them are arguing
you know what i mean what's the third
one doing while they're arguing trying
to
jump
inside trying to change the middle man
yeah that
nightmare i had a buddy who did an open
relationship forever well documented
abby marcus
nightmare he was so stressed out all the
time
think about it when you you think about
the chicken how'd you deal with you're
you're trying to
[ __ ] you're trying to you're trying
to
just like you're holding you're trying
to sue the girl they
are any girls i've heard like think
about that managing all those
personalities 20
no they probably all you know this
couple i'm telling you this is
this come from a dude who just got a
girlfriend for the first time
okay
you know to like think about thinking
about you have your queen now yeah if
you have that 83 year old
ruling out you got that 86 68 and that's
[ __ ] so don't get the first thing
so think if you had all those girls and
you have to
manage those personalities all the time
well you're basically the producer of
[ __ ] real love and hip hop you know
what i'm saying
like you're dealing with drama all but
how do you know if it's drama because
then it seemed dramatic when i was
they they were all pretty like oh you're
talking about your comedy show on
saturday night yeah dude
yeah they're out friday friday that
ain't real that's a good day
that's not real no it doesn't work out i
wonder
my boy i'll be marcus i mean he'll come
on here to talk about like he was like
dude i
it was like i would be doing his for a
minute a long time
sure i'm telling you man at the end of
the day it's a when they lay their head
down it's a nightmare
oh i couldn't and then mix then what
happens when one wants kids
then what you're gonna do you give both
of them kids
i know i don't think i could [ __ ]
ever do man well that's a lot because i
like now i hope it works out and good
for him that would be a great idea
no are you serious pimps they have the
men who
manage six seven eight girls oh
listen i saw we're not talking about
pence we're talking about a strictly a
relationship
yeah my god my friend my my dude like
back in the hood one of my homies he's a
pimp and he lived with his girls
and uh all of them they used to beat him
right so stressed out
he's got to be well yeah because they
yeah you got to be and that's
that's a lot that's too many [ __ ]
people bro and then you're dealing with
hookers yeah work not mentally stable to
start and then you're you're constantly
and then here's the other thing
you're basically an owner of a [ __ ]
nba team because they get older you
you can't you got to get new blood in
there
i'm not a pimp i don't know but you got
to find those girls who are open for
that business hey you remember it was a
porn star uh marcus
uh uh oh no brian pumper uh
oh hell yeah what nah don't he had the
fake jury he had all that goes on like
the
he goes to the gym and recruit women oh
you go on a train or he'll be on like
the city bus the city budget porno
no to recruit women to recruit women to
do porn yeah that's what i'm saying
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
would used to make fun of her
like like my cousin got approached by
him oh i was watching this documentary
there's this guy who drives a taxi and
he ends up [ __ ] the girls in the taxi
they talk about fake taxes yeah i know
i'm off the documentary i mean i'm in
them streets
see how long it took someone to catch up
to that all right know what you were
talking about i really was like oh
what's this
no no oh they're an attacker they pick
up girl with big titties yeah man
and then he's like hey forget the fear
just suck me off and
don't do it i love that i love those
guys you got a wheelish guy you got you
got a watch
it's an english guy you saw the
documentary on public agent
what's that oh it's a documentary where
he just like have women he'll pick him
up
they'll walk the street he's like hey
how you doing here stop like you look
like you can model
and it was like can you model for like
1500 euros right and she's like okay
cool
now can you you get one naked for like
three thousand euros he's like yo
can you suck me off for a hundred
thousand euros okay
and then i was like oh yeah i love the
bargain that's a dollar entry that's a
documentary it's a
real one no that's all your documents oh
word
i thought wait you know chin was
approached by a dude that said he
should be a model yeah did he want to
[ __ ] or he really wanted i don't know i
think
he gave me an actual car some gay stuff
though yeah yeah
dark gay action
have you ever seen the hbo documentary
on uh on uh hookers
confessions yeah you've seen that one
yeah and they mic that girl up and she's
working she catches john right
and she stayed miked up and he's just
you know he picks her up she gets in the
car and like damn what's happening how
far is hbo going to let this go
and you hear like slurping and then you
hear ooh
the camera is done there you go oh you
got that short fat dick
it's my favorite part in documentary
history
how do you guys find this [ __ ] yeah it's
like it's beal it's real
oh that's what you said like that's a
legit documentary
the other one the other one like i said
it was it was documentaries when
i was by myself oh yeah yeah
and i had the water faucet running i was
in the bathroom because i don't want to
hit anyone here that
don't want your queen enough yeah i'll
tell you what's [ __ ] up my
relationship
is uh married at first sight really
we're on season 10. this guy does not
start with this we're going to go
through it man
well because we'll be watching it and
then they'll talk about like the
qualities of each person while they work
and then my girl like well if i was on
the show what qualities would you give
me all right one this is not an obvious
and then this one
did you answer yeah i answered and then
uh they were talking about the one dime
piece we're talking about monday about
yeah
because the scientists because they go
and she's assigned to john hopkins
and one of her qualities or one of her
pros was she's uh educated my girl
i said you know my girl was would you
call me i'm like hot latina like beast
of a mom
loving sexy it's just good quality
educate i go
eat but yeah
no you did not you did not say that to
your queen
you did a quagmire you know right well
because
to me educated be someone with a masters
or higher like if you're going to listen
oh you're going to give her that no it's
something look at us
so many people that's my point that's
not your point
that's my point dude if you're gonna
list
off one of your strengths as educated
i'm like oh
doctor scientist master psychologist
something like that
you just can't have a bachelor's and be
listed as educated
i know people you're smart yeah yeah but
i'm but i think it's all relative i'm
knowledgeable i'm
i guess in like my lane but if you put
me next to jordan peterson
i'm peanut butter falcon you feel me
well you're also not calling her dumb
you're just saying
definitely guys that's my point i'm like
i'm like no like if someone asked me to
list off your
like i guess you're definitely educated
was different than yeah yeah
exactly exactly got it like there's no
arguments
right like a sexy latina she's like yeah
okay congratulations she's like and what
else i'm like
beast of a mom yeah that's a piece of a
mom like super motherly yeah
first date me and joanna ever went on i
went you know you're made to be a mom
right
she's like what the [ __ ] you thought it
off the rip rock
i was like you know you're you're
putting on search to be a mom she's wait
a minute
wait wait wait you're just super loving
kids yeah you're supposed to be a mom
a lot of women that could have went good
and bad for you yeah
it's not there anymore uh shout out to
covet it's called uh
it's called uh joe's and there's a
restaurant there
callan gave me uh the recommendation so
we go there
and uh she had like i remember she had
this nice purse and i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened at the time i had an
m6
it was an m6 uh yeah matt matt black
and had lime green brakes on it was sick
it was my first like real car
he was so sick she left she was telling
my personality yeah i know it's going to
want to have it coming against your car
an m6 girl
for what i don't know if it was some
option on the keys i've never seen this
before we walked back
all the windows are down the doors are
unlocked i'm like
oh [ __ ] my car got broken into like i
must have hit
every button on the [ __ ] thing in my
pocket and her but her purse was just
chilling there oh [ __ ] dude
crazy dude you know so the uh mine and
my girlfriend's uh
first date uh this [ __ ] about to be cute
it's gonna be a picnic let's take a
little break from the shenanigans
because listen
it's been reported that americans are
overpaying on car insurance
by over 21 billion dollars dollars
dollars dollars
but searching for a better car deal can
take hours and typically results in a
crazy unwanted spam calls listen forget
about all that
i gotcha the zebra.com the zebra.com is
the nation's leading car
insurance comparison site because it's
the only place you can compare quotes
side by side from over 100 providers
and choose the best for you in 90
seconds or less
also they will never sell your
information to the spammers
all right all you gotta do is answer a
quick few questions it's simple it's
fast and they find you the best rates
and coverage in your state
all right the best part is it's
completely
free you can save up to 670 a year using
the zebra.com
how much can you save on car and home
insurance go today
and start saving at the zebra.com
fighter that's the zebra like the animal
the zebra.com
fighter spelled t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a-dot-com
slash
fighter listen man ain't nothing like a
fresh shave a fresh
clean shave there's nothing better
there's also nothing better when you do
with harry's i'm talking about
go to harry's.com fighter you get
everything you need
to start for just three dollars harry
was founded by two friends
all right they want to cut out the
middleman they want to get you the best
razors possible
i'm talking about quality german
engineered blades all right
uh they have new sharper blades harry's
is delivering their sharpest
shave ever and they're raising the
prices all right
their new blades are so sharp guys are
shaving four times we reported
with harry's new blade their
eighth shave was as smooth as the first
crazy
quality guaranteed they comfortably
stand
by their blades with 100 money back
guaranteed on harrys.com
it's available online or in store
harry's available wherever you
shop harry's has a great offer for you
guys right now new
united states customers can redeem
harry's trial set at harrys.com
fighter for just three bucks you'll get
a five blade razor
featuring their new sharper blade a
weighted handle
foaming shave gel with aloe and a travel
cover to protect your blade when you're
on the go
just go to harrys.com fighter and redeem
your trial offer today for the best
blades on the market for the closest
shave ever
harrys.com fighter dude you know so
the uh mine and my girlfriend's uh first
date
uh this [ __ ] about to be cute yeah
you take that deep breath it's gonna be
a picnic
we went to like the top of this like
mountain like like overlooked uh the
valley and stuff we were sitting there
were you paying or something uh no where
the [ __ ] was it
somewhere in the hollywood hills okay
and uh we're sitting on this bench we're
sitting there talking
and then she like puts her head on my
shoulder and i just aggressively put my
arm around her and i uh i kissed her on
her forehead
and she [ __ ] those laughs
she's [ __ ] she brushed out laughing
bro you know how
my heart sank why because i was
embarrassed
all that [ __ ] is weird
[Applause]
she's like what am i what am i your
daughter
hike you know like so that would be your
first date no
i was with uh there's another person
with us
oh there's another one at a home at a
homie come use the throttle why'd you
invite him no i'm not a throuple
i just yeah why'd you invite a homie in
your first kind of hype he was nervous
yeah dude what'd you say he was nervous
um
she was like okay so then yeah you and
your buddy so yeah
and then you asked her out after that no
we just started kicking a little bit
more and then
you know it just like i don't know
organically happened and [ __ ] invited me
yeah when i
kissed her on the forehead bruh she
[ __ ] she was just like
was it one an impresso wasn't one that
wasn't one of them like powder on the
head
just squeeze the tighter too well you
you and your girl were like best friends
right chin so it's like we're already
close for
over 20 years damn
a lot of her girlfriends or her friends
i dated a few of her girlfriends
so it was absolutely chin and i remember
thinking like
she was always like to me the most
beautiful one i've seen right yeah look
at the girls that
yeah it's a windy road but then um what
was i going to say
oh oh my you thought she was the cutest
one the thought she was beautiful like
beautiful it was like the word i
and you got been you guys weren't close
to because you would always cool and my
girlfriends at the time
they would always say like oh do you
have something going on with her i'm
like no no we're just we're just super
close
so we ended up going you were secretly
hoping you did no that's another yeah
whatever i just thought she was really
beautiful
man brendan goddard
exactly you're sitting on it somebody
i'm sorry they're like man
this is [ __ ] where's the file in
this situation
because i knew it for so long it was
easy for me to to take her to disneyland
for our first date
yeah that was stuck in hennessy too
disneyland disneyland at night is the
move that's where
we did our first campaign because they
no i didn't do the foreign after
cheating i promise i'm gonna do it again
that'll rub it you gotta rub it like
warhead is old school
but i feel you but you gotta realize
this first
i mean here and there not a lot though i
feel like i just kind of hang out with
people here's my question have you had a
forehead kiss
i love forehead kisses thank you so much
those are the sacred thoughts those are
sacred those winners like yo
you forever even you're bald enough to
be that cheesy
you're a keeper it's my favorite you're
ballsy to be that's not cheesy
i think it's cheesy but it's cute kiss
yeah your queen i do it all the time you
hug a queen kiss
well you've been together for a while
your first kiss that's where it's kind
of like yeah that's why it's cheesy
first
you like that guy
right now all right that's a cute story
where did you go uh malekin your fruit
was there first yeah
yeah yeah you just came to the show in
phoenix yeah she came to but our first
official date was my indoor picnic
you did an indoor picnic so you had
dinner at home shout out to kovan
yeah i had to that's what she said why
did you say picnic well because i moved
the furniture around and i got this
big ass blanket and i tried to do [ __ ]
like that yeah and i gave her a review
and yeah so i was dope i was romantic
but i didn't know it was six figures i'd
take that back
i can't really cook i try to make like
this cute dinner and it failed
and i was like yo let's just order
something and she like yeah she was cool
and
yeah and look where you all are shout
out to first dates
chef birthdays are [ __ ] weird yeah
it's always it's always i guess
it's like dinner you do dinner right
mm-hmm the dumbasses are the ones that
do first dates and go to a movie theater
you can't talk yeah that is kind of dude
that's that's stupid that's real stupid
yeah that means no so
you're first what about a driving a nice
restaurant driving a little i mean
you're in the car the whole time that'd
be better than a movie
i should i took my ex on the drive-in
movie theater i knew [ __ ] i knew she was
a [ __ ]
because on the first
we watched ted two we didn't get through
the middle of the movie she's already
getting me hit
oh okay man i don't know if we could
blur that out but
i mean that's cool well that well that
that's like that mary that first sight
like
they so they they know each other for
three days right like they
they they they tell their family they
have the wedding that's the first time
they meet
they stay in the hotel that night
together awkward they don't know each
other
and then the next morning they dip out
their honeymoon to like antigua or
mexico yeah that's a nice place
so when they're on the honeymoon like
i've seen two seasons
there's only been one couple that had
sex the first night
oh really yeah my girl's like you would
you have sex the first time like
hey man what kind of question is that
yeah
i'm not watching this show to get your
judgment right she drops the questions
because your boy savage yeah
god damn i don't i mean i i if it felt
right i would i wouldn't put any
problems
but one dude was in trouble because when
the cameras were off he told the girl he
was like
listen this ain't gonna work out if we
don't have sex by the time we're done
with this honeymoon
and then she outed them she was like
yeah when cameras are on he's acting all
sweet then they're off he's making
threats and blah blah blah
so they slept in separate bedrooms you
just got to go your separate ways
so wait so they divorce on the third
date what do they do uh they're trying
to they have to stick it out though they
have to stick out for eight weeks at the
end of eight weeks they decide
they stay together to get divorced and
it's not a show where like people get
eliminated
no so everybody has to stay still if you
eliminate let me know for you come on
come
they stay together for eight weeks and
then so they get back from the honeymoon
and then they
rent them or lease them for whatever
eight weeks in apartments they live
together
then the end eight weeks they get
together the experts and decide if they
want to stay together they're not
i think season 10 that i on netflix i
think two out of the four stay together
couldn't do it but like and then there
was one with the one girl super nervous
and the dad was like you know
like he was all nervous and my girl's
like you know if we have a daughter
wouldn't you be nervous i'm like
no like i'd be like hey this ain't that
big of a deal
it's really not like everyone puts all
this pressure on marriage and stuff like
that
yeah this ain't [ __ ] like yeah i guess
the government's saying you guys are
together and you have to stay together
if not
they get half your [ __ ] but it's like
it's just a marriage like if it don't
work out we'll figure it out sure like
don't put too much pressure on yourself
who gives a [ __ ] try it if don't work
out
you'll find somebody else you know who
[ __ ] up marriage weddings
like the [ __ ] ceremonies and [ __ ]
what about the flowers all that stuff
the big the big weddings i can't go to
weddings dude i hate them
they don't they don't make a lot of
sense when you see him yeah but like me
my girl didn't do a big wedding i'm like
i told her i was gonna say yeah like
that it's tough because girls grow up
thinking of these big white wedding and
cinderella and all that [ __ ] yeah so
they're
they're all about it i told my grandma
like we can if you want that we can do
that yeah
or we just go to the courthouse because
we're in together forever have kids we
can go to the courthouse
and we'll take that money and put it
into our house or
yeah buy a car it's like there's
weddings so expensive yeah so expensive
single women all that
you thrive on the single women dude
they're so expensive yeah
singing yep i went to a couple of
bathrooms you don't look like you go to
weddings either you look like you go to
a lot of well yeah that's what a single
women's are
yeah what i thrive in sing bruh
especially at the speech i don't even
know the
wedding crashers over here yeah but bro
there's just so many a lot of
yeah and there's a lot of the
bridesmaids bridesmaids and then you go
in there with us dressed up as the tucks
and you handsome brother
i have so many bathrooms all the cars
that i just like thrive dude it isn't
really a waste of time
i'd rather you know save the money let's
just throw a [ __ ] party for everyone
and celebrate the marriage and then do
it at the crib or do it at a nice
restaurant and let's
save the [ __ ] money man yeah well i
think women i think they have this
facade that they want the big wedding
that well
that's like [ __ ] disney [ __ ] the guys
you know cinderella yeah we just played
yeah is that all we there was just i
guess it is different coming from us
what do you think that's a good question
a great question yeah that's a great
question
i wasn't raised in a family where a lot
of people got married so like i honestly
don't even care if i get married
i don't care about a wedding or anything
it's not yeah
no it's not dark most people are like
cat now most especially now most people
are moving more towards that
like if it happens it happens but i
don't care about having like this big
extravagant wedding
also divorce rate's up 53 so you're more
like if you're a betting man
no that's just high fifty times you're
more likely
why i mean it's just that's the numbers
the people especially
now in corona it's even worse because
you're on top of each other
but you're more likely to divorce than
not like to i've i guess maybe because
my parents got divorced around this kid
but like i don't
again i'm not did that affect you i'm
not anti-government but i don't give a
[ __ ] if this
if the state no you know says okay yeah
you're married here here's a contract
like
yeah yeah what does it have to do with
the state you got to die straight well
it's different when you have kids
because that i always told my grandma
you really don't want to get married
and then when we had kids and tiger was
going to school
you know tiger would have my last name
my girl didn't
she you know so they'd like why aren't
like she got a hyphen she got a hyphen
no
she just you know we weren't married so
she had her last name oh
so you you'll get judged by the other
moms for sure really it's just a bad
look
it's just a bad look don't judge that
[ __ ] why they care brother
instinct they business i was watching
big little lies and they like
really like these women are crazy they
really well it's that big little lie
it's a woman's show and they really like
hbo it's a great show by the way
people love that show yeah and they like
they judge you these women these women
that they're pretty sure she's like in
malibu area or something like that
they'll judge a woman off of like oh
little the little stuff
like you say oh you don't have your your
man's last name yeah it's true
it's strange or it's it's real caddy or
like where your kids going to school
right yeah i have that [ __ ] got
delivered
yeah like they judge all that stuff yeah
and it wasn't even those girls swinging
them hoes
straight up you know what i mean sorry
that was aggressive no no you you speak
your truth get it off your chest
i said if i was a girl i feel like it's
only in l.a though where that [ __ ] goes
down
like who my girl is telling you about
like judge where are your kids
i'm like who gives a [ __ ] yeah who gives
a [ __ ] that's the weirdest
that's the weirdest [ __ ] to care about
like to put that kind of what that
aren't they exhausted
oh you you take your kids to this school
but well
it's so competitive because schools only
allow like so my kids trying to get into
kindergarten they don't allow 20
students a year to get in those schools
that's a lot of kids
really and thinking about these kids are
in la so if they have to pass
uh intelligence tests with the teachers
in person and i'm gonna teach my kids
please
forget that you know what i'm saying
like this this new math is tricky
the the new [ __ ] this is the new shit's
a beastman
it's like i'm telling you it's harder
for my son to get in these big schools
that we want to get into than it was
for for me to get into college yeah like
the amount of testing he has to go
through and the in-person
interviews and we have to meet with the
teachers and the
there's a director of staffing and like
i've done all these zooms and [ __ ]
it's nuts and then i was like why the
[ __ ] so crazy
well because all these schools only
allow 20
kids a year into their [ __ ] program
it's k
through 12. so it's a big decision yeah
tuition
you [ __ ] kidding me they take all
tuition people paying for
[ __ ] grade school now again this is
new math it's crazy please excuse my
dear on sally
you're talking dude really beast
la's a beast man with schools starts
young too it'll keep me up at night
because you got to hope your kid goes to
good school i love public school this
[ __ ] was tight
oh yeah you say that until you look at
la public schools
and you pay all these taxes you're like
how are the taxes not helping these
schools
oh really the worst schools in this i
mean yeah my school's some of the worst
in the nation my school was
where do we rank in like the country not
good not good
not horrible i think we're like in the
middle tier but isn't texas the best
texas best yeah texas no because barbara
bush when she was the first lady
she was a teacher so you know sometimes
those first ladies do [ __ ]
and she decided it's very rare so
something like that
i had to have the weakest jobs ever uh
trump trump's wife's is uh anti-bullying
online whatever so barbara bush she was
a former teacher so she put all these
resources in the public school system
so texas schools are beasty damn like
they rank them out of 10
most texas schools like 10 out of 10 9
out of 10 10 out of 10
like all across the board but i felt
like i got a great education
depends like you go to a good school i'm
like oh i didn't learn [ __ ] like i
didn't learn [ __ ] i don't even
think you learned [ __ ] no granted you
cheated in college
damn yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't know
that's your situation
well he was telling me but college is
what you you get in what you put into it
college if you're looking for education
you're going to find it at a major
university like university of colorado
you're going to find a [ __ ] you're going
to find it i was majoring in football
yeah like unless my kid's [ __ ] gifted
in
football he ain't going to school for
football unless he's just a beast at him
like all right yeah you're probably
watching
this no because your major is football
yeah like all you're doing is football
dude and they try to say like oh
but we we give you an education too you
don't they give you the easiest class
graduated he got his degree at phoenix
college
or something like that university of
phoenix university well you went to pitt
and then he got his degree after from
because after like he left after two
years at pitt yeah so yeah but he got it
during when he was playing in the
university of phoenix
nationwide nationwide thing oh wait it's
like it's like
uh
yeah come on come on get out you gonna
do we're gonna do what you like come on
down to icdc college yeah
there's only like 10 of us it's like
nicki minaj got that degree from harvard
right there like she got into harvard
yeah i think it was like sierra i was
like online harvard oh really
i'm gonna try to get it's just to say
she's got a degree from harvard yeah hey
cuevo uh got his high school diploma he
got it back
you know good for him didn't he do it
because his uh girl told them that
education is important yep he's queen
love it up sweetie i respect him
cuz she she's a uh yeah she went to usc
the same time i went to usc
oh yeah so you know her i didn't know
her i knew she went to
she was like one of the bigger alumni
oh so you knew her oh
no ufc has 30 000 students
[ __ ] i apologize i mean
hey that's dope yeah but good for him
yeah but about hear what you're saying
about the education like
so you said down south they're more
committed towards like educate well
you just you know i don't think down
south like no [ __ ] no like
dude university of california schools
yeah university of california
lots of asians ucla there's i mean
there's a reason why it's full of asians
because they pride themselves on the
education
oh yeah that's why there's so many
asians in schools in l.a
yeah well kind of all over now yeah like
orange county dude harvard
what about koreatown dude you don't want
to you know koreatown university
you know harvard they're they're going
to pass a law where they're they're
making it tougher for asians to get in
because so many asians yeah during their
application they put different uh
prerequisites like you have to do an
interview and that's based off your
personality too not necessarily
because what kind
honestly that's where like affirmative
action kind of screws asian people
because then it's like if more asians
are
getting like better grade point averages
or whatever they're like okay there's
too much of you guys
so we need to lessen the amount of
what's your personality like
yeah so they will put something else in
to give you a reason why you didn't get
it
but what are they looking for in a
personality they don't
looking for like dry personality what
are they looking for
have you worked at the apple store yeah
yeah what are they looking for it's
something they have to come up with
otherwise all the university would be
asians what's wrong with that wait what
i like
listen i'm a conservative i think
whoever's the smartest should get
i don't give a [ __ ] whoever's the
smartest who comes with the best
business plans talent
you get the talent it makes the most
money that's yours yeah that nobody
should because there's some great
business people with shitty
personalities
like mark zuckerberg i don't know him he
created facebook
created facebook he he went to a
apartment and dropped out
he dropped out he was like yo so would
you do you applaud people like that like
go to these big time colleges and just
like you know what i mean
here's the problem now yeah hell yeah
like college isn't for everybody
the other thing is like mark zuckerberg
so many people
at that level who are that smart gone to
harvard they're dropping out creating
apps
so they're only there for like two years
so the dropout rate started to
increase because so many people are like
i'm just going to create an app and be
mark zuckerberg
oh oh change that meter
i got it i got it you got it thank you
kat it's it's it's amazing
yeah she knows what car it is
because like he's driving he's like real
low and i'm like up high so it looks
awkward
so that guy that did our tattoos he
messaged me
he's been getting a lot of love yeah
dude he was like dude
he was like thank you for helping me and
my family oh don't i was like damn okay
homie i don't know
well he hasn't his work speaks for
itself his work speaks to him yeah he's
yeah he's really good yeah he's got
people like flying in to go
i was i was i was laughing thinking
about this the other day we got some
random ass tattoos because we think
about it justin got a kobe bryant tattoo
he's from florida
you got a voices tattoo which is not
really not from manchester
you're you know what i'm saying it's
just it's kind of rare it's just
we all have a random video i got a texas
tattoo i have no
i don't know who's the weirdest i'm not
from texas i'm not from texas i'm saying
but you love yourself
and three c's i i love texas and i love
uh
oh chappelle dropped his new merch by
the way oh damn dog
yeah well you changed your life you
changed your icon
yeah icon why is that baby who's that
who's that is that you
baby pig look at that look at that why
is that black baby in the background
oh that black baby yeah oh that's me
thank you that's why i asked did you
change it
because i don't know why who are you
using to make your mirror
no one of my home long time homies back
home in arizona
uh my buddy tim kurtz shout out to him
man i love this touchdown thanks for the
gift bag of merch doug
all the merch i've given you oh wait
nevermind all the sick boy gary hey tim
if you're listening we got to hook up
brenda what's up xl
tim i need that jacket yeah sure
yeah shout out to tim kurtz right media
a medium that's the hobby that uh
did it uh wait yeah dude he goes man he
goes so many people been
flying out to me and you know uh to
[ __ ]
get tattooed but our tattoos are random
i have no association with texas the
only reason i got it
it's my it's literally my favorite state
probably probably my favorite state do
stand up in i've always
even when i first started headlighting i
sold out there
you've always been ride or died look at
it there we are i can tell because
y'all every show was electric every
everyone every show was i don't think
they had a bad show we don't have badges
guys real quick uh you guys
might have to just move your cars
because you can't re-upload the parking
spot you can't if you have a different
uh credit card
oh a different credit card yeah uh i
tried to put a coin in it didn't work
here use mine i think you have to wait
until all the time runs up yeah yeah
yeah left so it
runs out at 199
oh what's so funny about the tattoos we
got though
random tattoos also from florida but
also no association with kobe bryant
well
also like the easiest stuff he's
probably ever done
compared to the work he does probably
here you okay the easiest
the easiest [ __ ] did we talk about like
how much justin tipped and he had the
biggest tattoo oh
bro he said he said not you guys got him
he misses the first show getting it done
yeah
he's a kobe bryant i'm like all right
you're from florida whatever he is a
giant
kobe tattoo he played basketball i did
too
hey brenda got a mean euro step you
ain't seen it he doesn't
come over the crib
but yeah justin tells me we like just
how much did you tip him
he goes uh about a hundred dollars no
he's not like 80. no 89.99
he first oh yeah i was about a hundred
and i actually
what's about a hundred i accidentally
was well 89 i rounded up to 100.
what you took the man eighty nine
dollars now here's the
other one you got that large ass tattoo
hey you know what's funny the dude drove
them to the show oh yeah the dude
so so let me tell you the story so the
guy
he didn't typical venue was like 25
minutes away oh my
god listen he didn't he didn't venmo him
until he was like midway through the
so he was like okay i forgot he was like
yeah man whatever you want to give you
can just get here's all right i got you
so he waited 89
he was like so then he said when the
thing hit
when they hit his phone he was like man
i think i preach
so [ __ ] funny dude go to the next one
i think that's what he yeah there it is
lift fava
did you ever did everyone get one uh jay
got one jay
justin me and chappelle yeah oh clogged
in does cop even have to talk as well
yeah he has one tattoo me jay and cop
have the same tattoo but i mean like the
the dude was up yeah he reached out to
me he goes dude thank you so much you
know that's awesome i'm like your work
speaks for itself homie you know yeah if
you weren't good we sure as [ __ ]
yeah i wouldn't say [ __ ] y'all said
y'all said to me
like literally look at the work he's
doing compared to like what
we got we just got the most basic
severed justin justin yeah he got the
kobe
with the mambo also let's get the texas
i know and the [ __ ] he said 89 v
logo on his leg let me speak my truth
real quick one of my friends just he got
a full
leg tattoo sleeve yeah he gave him 80
bucks like that size right there the
whole on his calf
oh you guys have to move oh really
apparently still didn't work
that didn't make sense that doesn't make
sense if i parked my car there they
wouldn't know
that that has no clue what car is there
yeah it won't take in your card either
it won't take anybody's card
no i put in a coin i put in your card oh
so that means it's broke
the limit is uh okay it has exceeded
that means it's pretty yeah then i can
give it to you if they even take it i'll
pay for it
that means just oh meaning like they're
not gonna charge anymore
it says the limit is has been reached
and the time has expired
so it says like you need to pay but
won't take any money so it's flashing
red
yeah okay if you take it i'll pay for it
okay that's a real friend
all right we'll fight it but i don't
have that kind of time um
but you got a question that dude's joke
but i told you
i tell i tell him to see all the time
nothing's free yeah
we did a bunch of podcasts with that man
oh yeah people go come to the restaurant
i tell you it's not free because i'm
gonna have to sit there and do a goddamn
podcast
while you guys eat just talk yeah i
gotta talk
and take pictures and entertain yeah
look at that spider that looks crazy
real that's crazy
oh gosh here's the thing ah
damn that's dope black widows don't have
red markings on their backpacks they do
that no they don't that's not spiderman
i saw spiderman they haven't is it all
they're doing
no only on their bellies bring up
pictures of black widows
i have them all around the corner we
have them all around in there
i don't know for a fact if they don't
have them on all of them but that's what
i remember the best they only have them
on their bellies that's how you tell it
oh
look at the back right there look at
that where's the black one right there
look at the top right look at that big
ass that is not the belly
yeah oh yeah there you go you're right
bro i studied this animal [ __ ]
that tattoo's legit would you get a
black widow yeah hell yeah that is
that's dope huh that's a dope tattoo
i don't like one it means something
though in prison when you get a black
widow
i mean doesn't it you kill somebody
bring up no i think that's a tear no
that's a tear oh the though the web
means you did time in prison
oh yeah yeah anytime soon the web but
not now they know the the
prison like yeah there you go tattoos
used by men in prison the spider tattoo
or web tattoos used to represent their
inc
yes trapped in prison like being kind of
webb
the black widow tattoos also use a
symbol of fear and death yeah like you
kill someone oh wow
yeah my friend is dark but i would get
one yeah you get one
i may have a [ __ ] skull why not do
you want a snake too
i'll get a snake yeah yeah yeah i'd do
that you get a snake
hold pipe rattlesnakes you [ __ ] see
on the regular i do that
i'm on the road now though so i don't
see many rattlesnakes
oh yeah i saw you posted you was on the
road road road
yeah you jump rope this morning oh you
did hey bruh
a lot of people have been hitting me up
they said we could get shredded we can
we could do it oh did your bo what would
you oh mark's down what do you see he's
so down what do you say dude he wants to
help us
he does yeah you tell me i don't know
exactly what he [ __ ] needs to do with
us ask him say
where how do we start is there a diet
plan yeah yeah yeah some steroids i'm
wearing
i'm not i'm not with steroids you're not
in this competition
you're already skinny i'm trying to come
up i'm trying to try to be extra
shredded no i'm trying to come up to you
you and justin should have a competition
put on weight
that's a very competitive who could get
fat who could get fat
wait what no yeah they'd be sick bulk up
you know how much funnier you guys would
be if you're fat
i don't think i think people be giggling
at me all the [ __ ] time right
half my last because my size yeah come
on now come on now come on skip come on
skip i gotta dedicate i gotta dedicate
it to the crowd
but um what does it say yeah he's
totally down to do it
but uh when do we wanna start after i
get back from montana so next week we'll
start so next week we'll start and what
we're going to do
is the first official day a month of
kicking ass i would say to january 1st
look at you so it's into a month you
don't think i can get shredded in a
month
absolutely not you don't know me i do
know that's kind of i know how the body
works right you're not a monster ain't
getting shredded
you act like you know my body this is
your body no human body
you ain't getting shredded a month
homeboy oh [ __ ] you see jared cannon
here
do you see him oh you talking about that
professional athlete on tv yeah
who's
we're a far cry from jared cannon air
dog i was watching the countdown with
him that boy is shred
city there he is all three faces
oh three come on now come on chappelle
top left
[Laughter]
for real that's real on the left but
then we get him on the
hill right now that when he's on the
scale what is it what is that
what is it he's got 185 there
you're talking about real dedication so
if he can do it you can do it brendan
that's what i'm saying
you don't believe in yourself i believe
he puts me in it too yeah exactly huh we
believe in you so much that you try to
pour
i bet you could be like [ __ ] have you
shredded i'd love to hear homeboys
playing
all right all right but you got our back
i know but you gotta dedicate you got
your wallet
he sent us a plan i'm in start next
tuesday okay starting next tuesday
i had a rice krispie treat on the way
here today when's the last time you had
a rice krispy treat it's been a while
bro i had 16 two weeks ago when i was
home
sixteen in one sitting like there was
like the coffee i just
yeah i just put them down dog a nice
dark roast with a [ __ ] rice krispie
treat
dark roast
my uh samples from my whiskey get here
today
okay working on this uh american bourbon
japanese blend look at you yeah first to
market we'll see
bruh state you bro man stay hustling in
the streets y'all better go
give your flowers while you're alive
mm-hmm all that whiskey you never
[ __ ] wild turkey that was my life i
like wild turkey
i would get down on some wild turkey how
you said it you still miss it
oh yeah i saw it i i i literally i drink
whiskey
every night i told my girl i said when
we get back from montana i'm not going
to drink at home
anymore only now if there's something to
celebrate because we started watching
[ __ ]
uh yellowstone i was wearing a cowboy
hat drinking whiskey every night because
they drink whiskey on that show yeah and
then that show stopped and i just kept
going
you get oh she goes you're gonna get
whiskey for married at first slice
you were like you kept on keeping passed
them up you messed them up
damn you know shut up yeah whiskey boy
you always been that way
no [ __ ] no you were you were long
no when i first started this podcast i
didn't drink at all i didn't start
drinking it tonight i was talking about
like
two years ago oh i was like drinking
drinking bread now in college i barely
drank
oh really didn't drink when i was in the
ufc
i didn't start drinking really rogan got
me on whiskey
i did a shot with him before that's how
i have it
i did a shot with him i think he was
probably uh jim bean or
uh [ __ ] jack daniels i did a shot
with him he was like i'm telling it's
gonna lose you up you have a good set
like
i just said i don't like to do it had a
great
set and i was like all right here we go
you know it was wild when i when i used
to drink
you know i would never drink before a
show or anything like that i never did
it like that i enjoy it
yeah because one time i did get drunk
and the whole crowd was just [ __ ]
cussing me out
robbie threw up on them no i didn't
throw up on them they just [ __ ] just
started yelling at me talking [ __ ] to me
were you having a bad set though man i
was only like
a minute and a half in they didn't give
you a [ __ ] yeah it was so cuz someone
kept yelling
something and i was like hey you know
oh so i remember what happened so it was
the show i was doing
at this spot back in arizona called
martini ranch
and it was a bunch of bands that were
playing so i thought i was going to open
the show and this is like my fourth set
ever okay and i thought yo uh uh i
thought i was going to open the show for
all the bands
no all the bands played then the dj came
on
turned into a little dancing and then
the dj was going to take a break
and then i was going to go what a
nightmare set up for let me tell you
i was so hyped i was on one because i
was you know
it was my fourth set and i was already
killed my first three sets before
you know and as soon as i grabbed that
microphone
i knew well they're not in the right
frame of mind everybody was [ __ ]
wasted man i remember i wouldn't blame
the alcohol
this [ __ ] that ain't the alcohol
that's that shitty crowd
oh no it's not you it was the crowd
yeah yeah yeah cause then some someone
was yelling for a band but they already
had played and i was like yo they
already
[ __ ] played and then i think i said
shut your fat ass up
it was a fat person something like that
something like that yeah and then all of
a sudden
everybody just started attacking me dude
dude i remember my adopted father was
there he's all christian as [ __ ]
man shake your fat ass i'm telling the
crowd to suck my dick and all this [ __ ]
what did he say to you afterwards what
do you say your adopted dad when he was
like hey you tried
you support him like that because i was
like man i'm sitting here
suck my dick [ __ ] my dick suck my [ __ ]
someone was like your dick's the joke
and i was like i don't have a reply for
that [ __ ]
so then i'm just it's off to the races
yeah
and oh then what made me mad is i get
off stage
and the people that were yelling at me
started buying me drinks
weird yes so weird they basically just
wanted you to get off stage
yeah i mean i respect that yeah yeah i
didn't even like say
bye or anything the dj's just turned on
i was like that dude got knocked out
he's all dj
i remember that yeah he's yeah dj hit me
i i saw my friend had a uh like a set
that was bad and then the fight broke
out
oh um teddy teddy uh big teddy ray oh
i did the show yeah all the way to
college it was a fight broke out it was
uh
they had good uh you're performing
compton man
it was some real [ __ ] like i was on
stage a fight broke out
oh and then the dude finished this he
finished his set yeah
and some game banging stuff and he's
like all right come outside so we
everybody just he was like man he was in
the middle of his punchline it was
talking [ __ ]
and then he was like man come outside
then because i'll be right back
and then did he [ __ ] him up yeah we went
outside and i was like man y'all need to
do this y'all need to do this i was like
yes they do
yeah i want to see some [ __ ] oh you you
wanted it but because they do kept
interrupting the whole night they were
drunk and then it was
like prior beef and then uh they were
i remember they was fighting then the
promoter wanted to like get in like
break it up and
i was like hold on time out don't do
that yet you didn't pay me
let's get that let you pay me first get
my money and then they had like a big
brawl in the street
then literally he's like all right man
i'm sorry about that where was i
and then like everybody came it was the
crowd cool with it it was black all
black people they were there was eating
a chicken with like he started talking
[ __ ] it made his set funnier because he
started talking about
yeah he broke it down and then he killed
him yeah
i don't want that to ever happen
that's why i understand compton
i wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't
advertise guys
you don't think they would i think they
probably would i think they yeah i used
to do chocolate sundaes that
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i bet they would yeah you got a lot of
black people in your life yeah for sure
i was about to say bro
it's a lot of black people showing up to
your shows now oh yeah come on man come
on now
come on they know you messing with the
swirl come on skip squirrel
the swirl now bro i mean i respect it
come on show up
uh what do you got for caravan it's a
chocolate sundaes is actually actual
name or do you guys just
call it sundays yeah yeah dude that's
like
literally one of the best shows yeah i
used to do it every sunday yeah yeah
i stopped working on sunday man honestly
it's like
you once you know you killing in that
room you know you got something oh yeah
cause some black people they be in there
all
right
it's like a snack i call it snapchat
crowd you got 10 seconds
yeah before they alright let me always
tell people black audiences
are the [ __ ] best they're the best
they'll make you because they'll tell
you on site yeah you [ __ ] suck
because that roast you yeah but if they
rock with you they rock with you hard i
love that
hell yeah right now if they don't like
you they're not gonna [ __ ] write a
blog
they're not gonna go on twitter and
they're not gonna say you like that
dance at the show no they're gonna let
you bro that suck
they roast you that ain't funny not like
oh you playing you're annoying now
they'll be like yo listen
give up yeah yeah yeah they'll say it
right on right hey bro get back
even with the with singing when i do
competitions with my group mm-hmm
we would always look at where the black
crowds were this is how they're digging
it
i'm not even kidding i'm not kidding
when they were digging it we were like
[ __ ] yeah it's a great feeling yeah it's
a great feeling
cause you know black people we express
we don't just laugh we was like man that
[ __ ] funny kept going
yeah yeah like well i'm gonna keep going
like they express it
yeah so and with seeing you come on the
best yeah the best
yes you're singing yeah that was just
one white dude in the crowd who's not
laughing like what's wrong with him
i was gonna see him after like dude that
was a fun show it's like yeah he's like
i was like
[ __ ] ain't you laughing yeah right yeah
yeah that's always the weirdest [ __ ]
the white one white guy i'm like who
searched him did anybody search this
white dude what's this
so uh nicholas cage met up with marilyn
manson
and they did a podcast where there's
podcast
it's marilyn manson's podcast i didn't
know he had one um
everybody had one though they looked
good everyone and their grandma has a
podcast now
but he talked about a story where the
last time he gambled he was in the
bahamas
he turned 20 into 20 grand he ended up
going to the local orphanage
gave them that money and stopped
gambling for the rest of his life thus
wow
they both look like [ __ ] they look rough
they look so rough so rough no marilyn
manson's always looked great i know
dog marilyn manson looks like [ __ ] you
hug you hug him he gonna put all that
makeup on your face hell no you remember
that
marilyn manson like uh produces a bunch
of uh
rap now like hip-hop oh yeah he does
like like uh a little oozy
little uzi vert he doesn't know oh he's
doing this oh he's doing his uh next
album
yeah he loves uh he's responsible for
like a ton of
hip-hop like top hip-hop songs he's got
i mean
i've seen him in i saw him uh with it
was him and rob zombie
it was a dope ash oh damn that's
happening yeah
ferguson damn yeah he does a lot of
hip-hop now marilyn manson
yeah they love his world because they're
jumping into that like world of like
weirdness and it's like
[ __ ] yeah but musically like he knows
this [ __ ] yeah he's oh merely yeah he's
a weirdo but he knows his [ __ ] he was on
how to expect it
don't know justin timberlake oh i have a
one of my boys went to uh a club and
marilyn manson was there
i forget who it is he went to a club and
he
he knows marilyn a little bit he went to
his house he says his house is all
like everything's like dark like there's
no sunlight gets in
it has a special unit ac unit where the
house gets like
all like 40 degrees yeah it's freezing
in there he wants it freezing right
and like vampire yeah yeah [ __ ]
everywhere like white [ __ ] yeah limit
no he just likes that he's just like so
then they go they go to the club
and he has like these these big he has
these big like boots on
and the dudes serving the bottle service
spilled like an
entire thing of oj into his shoe oh
he said he just didn't give a [ __ ] just
kept on keeping on dude he's
he's a real one his interviews are great
if you ever watch this i'm a marilyn
manson fan
yeah he's got some great interviews
where people just try to attack him and
come at him and he's just
really he's just so mellow yeah he's
ready for all of it
he's always he's a smart dude yeah he's
he's really smart that's the thing
like he exposes them more than me for
what
just like his what he does like you know
like him being dracula
it was more so back in that like time
when he like first came out
like he went on a o'reilly factor and
that's like a great interview because
o'reilly's like
they're coming at him because i remember
the columbine kids
yeah they came out like columbine and
other other stuff too
you know what i mean like just why the
lyrics why this and he's just like i'm
just
i'm just an individual like he's just
yeah he's just all about individuality
can i see him without makeup i just want
to see what he really looks like it's
just what he looks like without makeup
there was a huge rumor he was the kid
from the wonder years
but he's not no i don't know what his
background is we're like where he's from
he's from florida
that makes sense oh wow everybody
everybody want to hear
everybody weird in florida not everybody
he was on sons of anarchy
season seven he looked like rachel
maddow i think
six or seven yeah that's him my son's a
man he's a cool dude
there's also the room where he took out
one of his ribs so he could suck his own
dick i heard about that i heard about
that
yeah that's a little bit more now is
that true he did not do that
you ride a little too hard on his white
nuts what yeah
[ __ ] because i think that the rip thing
might be true
like is that that crazy you think it's
that crazy i mean girls take out their
ribs to have smaller waists
now yeah but not not to get yourself no
he did not
[ __ ] do that that's that's a lot of
suckers on dingling on stage
y'all don't man first of all marilyn
manson marilyn manson's not even the
craziest person to ever hit the stage in
the rock world
who's the craziest gg allen from
from the murder junkies oh my god what a
name yeah
dude he was a nut he would pee on you
yeah yeah yeah but uh ozzy osbourne when
he was young was crazy too when he took
the bat and
i don't think he was i don't think
anyone's been as crazy as the dude ggs
he's pretty [ __ ] crazy he is what
what's the craziest [ __ ] he did
dude he would literally literally [ __ ]
on stage
and then eat it and then he would throw
it at the crowd and the people still be
in the audience like
dude he was a nut oh that's on my [ __ ]
my [ __ ]
oh okay i see what you did there good
afternoon
come on man believe that marilyn manson
still won't say whether or not he
removed a rib in order to suck his own
dick two decades
i love dude i love it i love that he
won't say he still refuses to answer the
question now y'all goddamn business
exactly
i don't yeah that's why i don't give any
[ __ ]
if you want to remove your ribbon suck
your dick remove your ribbon
he goes listen i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't know why
i don't know why people care it's yeah
it's like why do you get why do you need
that if he wants to take out his rib and
suck his dick at night all right yeah
this guy
we don't need it we don't need to know
everything yeah we try to know too much
he must be you want to know what's
possible like what about the guy who
spit on you and it was spit
was with the rocks it was a concert i
went to when i was like 15.
it was it was this band called the
casualties and i was
uh i was you're i was singing yeah
jamming out singing i was excited it was
my first time seeing them
and the dude was like spitting in the
crowd and [ __ ] and then
you know i'm trying to like you know
dodge the [ __ ] and i'm singing this song
one of my favorite songs
and this dude spit into that crowd that
[ __ ] landed right on my tongue
like spit spit spit spit yeah looky
yeah right on my tongue i'm gonna drink
some water because i was like
and then boom ugh yeah spitting on
people
no what did you do what did you punks
can be like the most
dirty [ __ ] sometimes yeah it
was no it was not
it was not i heard i heard rock stars
don't take showers what
they don't take back yeah they don't
come where's he find that
i heard rappers don't take showers [ __ ]
that's a damn lie well i hope not what
happened
okay so on twitter somebody made a post
where
they put it was chris evans chris pine
chris pratt and chris hemsworth in a
bubble and says one has to go
people were then like are you in the
comments someone post this
yeah i don't know [ __ ] like this they're
bored somebody did it i think they were
doing it out of like
lighthearted fun but it ended up
becoming like a
chris pratt like after chris pratt
because he's very important uh because
he's very christian and it's not even
that he's a trump supporter it's that he
isn't political like he purposefully
tries to stay away from politics
and he just kind of does his own thing
he's very religious but he doesn't
really talk about it
uh and people assume that he is a trump
supporter because he's christian and
conservative
uh mark ruffalo ended up coming out and
defending they came out
no they came out to defend him you know
how to defend him yeah
yeah and they're just like what is wrong
with you like he just doesn't want to be
political like leave him alone
you know what let's keep our eye on the
prize we're so damn
whack i swear why is that
mark ruffalo though i mean we talking
about hulk here so let's try it lightly
no [ __ ] hulk oh my god dude that's not
your favorite character
no who's your favorite buffalo is not my
favorite character oh i thought it was
something
i don't really know he's so anti just
that he's on another level
what is he what is he believing i don't
know too much about dude yeah i don't
know
he's a beta male he wants well ain't
nothing wrong with a pro body there's
something wrong with that he's pro biden
copy that
super pro like
[Laughter]
all right don't get me started
he's about to jump on it oh
right yeah hell yeah dawg this one
invite
jay um so 50 and um
he came out and basically endorsed trump
because of biden's
like tax outline where he wants to
endorse semester yeah because
somebody and somebody ended up making a
joke saying that like he doesn't want to
be 20
he wants to stay 50 cent he doesn't want
to pay 62 of taxes
and uh i believe ice cube was then like
dragged into it because the republican
party came out and tried to
like have a meeting with him about
certain things of
i guess just talking about like how can
we do better with the black community
yeah but he said that the republican
party didn't reach out to him here's
what happened with ice cube
ice cube said i have some ideas reach
out to the democratic party
reach out the republican party democrats
never got back to them they don't want
to [ __ ] with them
the republican party was like yeah what
do you want to do well we're down to
ride with you
so he's not it's not that he's super pro
trump the the only ones that got back
yeah exactly was it democrats day phone
was off that day
he's always he's always preached like
okay i don't care
the democratic republican what are you
going to do for me talk to you
i think that's what he's always everyone
killer mike's the same all of us are
like that
yeah yeah i don't like either of them
but the thing is is like
with biden so whichever whichever way
you're going to vote that's your thing i
don't judge anybody
based off the way they vote but if you
with biden's tax plan if they if they
tax people who make over 400k
60 60 percent anybody who makes over
400k is going to leave california
they're just going to [ __ ] dip out in
those states they want to do the 60
so who do you think's going to be
responsible for that even
all you guys the the middle class gonna
have to make up that difference
oh he said all you guys those smart
people are gonna get out
i'm waiting i get it i'm not honda yeah
what time i'm in the sixth biggest
category hell no
are you in the six-week world she is
well she is that is
that debate's tomorrow night too i can't
wait they gonna mute trump how you feel
about it i don't
i i just don't see how i don't see how
biden's gonna show up with the that news
that that bombshell news that's
dropped with his son you guys know this
stuff
well let me put you on game real quick i
love when y'all
this is where i go for all my dudes so
here's here
all politicians are [ __ ] corrupt all
of them i don't give a [ __ ] which one
you
vote for which one you ride with they're
all corrupt biden's corrupt he's a
lifelong politician there's there's
going to be a [ __ ]
laundry list of bad [ __ ] that he's done
right i've been a politician forever
yeah so his son who's a former drug
addict current drug addict
they had him dealing with international
affairs with china and ukraine
he has no background in any of it with
international affairs
so everyone's kinda like that's weird
whatever his dad's joe biden
this [ __ ] [ __ ] this
dumbass his son his son
this dumbass hunter biden drops off his
laptop to a
computer shop like a small mom-and-pop
computer shop in new hampshire drops off
there
forgets about it leaves it there well
the way that works
if it's there left over time the the
owner of the shop
looks into it like whose computer you
know to give it back to him or whatever
he looks it up this dude that's all
the chats of him talking to ukraine
and china making deals in his dad's
interest
has the whole longest they have pictures
of him smoking crack
crack pipes he's doing cracking
and and this just dropped and and then
there's also
biden having deals with china and
ukraine oh you're talking about the
talking
about illegal [ __ ] oh trump about the
talking [ __ ]
i don't see how biden i don't i don't
see and they're not denying the claims
they're just not saying anything but
he's going to be forced to say something
during
tomorrow night's debate trump you're
gonna give him two minutes
every two minutes can be that that what
yeah answer that answer that yeah i can
see that yeah
but i i feel you on that computer shop
when they leave your stuff
put it in there for too long dude
computer but if i would you leave it
if i'm if i'm joe biden why would you
trust your son who's a goddamn crackhead
to negotiate for you in any facet in
international affairs
of course he's going to [ __ ] it up yeah
um they're all corrupt
you're so stupid you saw
have you ever seen that picture of nick
cannon at the i think it was the knicks
game or lakers game
and he walks by beyonce and jay-z and
he's dressed like in that get up and
even they're like god damn
are you serious yeah like they're like
yo you over doing it a little bit
let's see nah man let my man express
himself
oh right here yeah they look at him like
he's weird yeah they're not they're
looking like
who is they trying to figure him out
there i see he's kind of bounced back
from his i haven't heard from him have
you guys
man yeah he's been out there no i've
seen anything you say things about the
jews you got to sit out the next year
i think the only thing i've seen about
him post saying
the like jewish stuff was that he had
like a podcast with a rabbi
on his show and they kind of talked
about it that's the way he went like
super defensive for jews now so he like
went to all these like
apologies uh holocaust
like he's on intermittent fashion now i
was like you might have
super pro jews i'm not fashion
he's lost kind of the black support and
then the jews are like i guess we'll
take him like
man i'll still watch drumline i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah i
i don't care people want to throw them
on i'm a huge nick cannon chain i think
i love
and no one gives a [ __ ] about it and
also it makes him no money now so by him
like i bet
i bet he still makes more money some
residuals
trust me he can't live off drumline no
i'm saying
he has the mad singer that's still
airing on fox fox didn't release him
they still they
they because that's the show though
right but he uh it's not that shows for
the people keep saying nick cannon
created mad senior yeah mass singer was
a show in korea
over here oh okay he's just a producer
of the show but he didn't
invent mask singer so why they didn't
fire him
fox stood by him because by the time
they came about it he
actually apologized his his initial
mistake besides the stupid [ __ ] he said
and didn't educate himself
going bad against the jews he didn't
apologize for it
he bet he he went back down from it so
viacom was like
well we can't have this dude so they let
him go of all his [ __ ] they said
and then he apologized but while the
house still exists would you well
they took him bro what are you talking
about oh yeah your favorite your
favorite rapper isn't
willing out perkin your favorite
freestyle rapper no while in out
they all think [ __ ] kids they created
while and out yeah and via competition
what's that they shut all that down that
was about to say if he owned it no he
really didn't own it because he was like
man they swindled me out of what three
billion dollars or some viacom
because it was like oh you thought you
owned it but you really didn't and now
he
that's what in the contract you know
that's why they say read the fine print
oh come on man get some but you can't do
that show without him like you're like
making a while enough yeah
listen the jews got so much money i was
like i would just dump it
wow yeah and here's the thing it was
doing really good because it made a
comeback [ __ ] i was trying to get on it
i like this [ __ ] yeah you should oh yeah
yeah i mean ridiculousness is their
flagship but yeah yeah
while on that was i that was that was
dope yeah and they have the clips that
they
wow wow they got so many people come out
the wild girls the wild now girls oh
yeah where what
i was like you know pete davidson was on
there he was on the original cast
yeah when he was like 16 or 17 yeah he
was young
uh mikey day as well mikey he's on snl
yeah cat williams was on there yeah yeah
i remember when cat was on it
holy [ __ ] yeah d-ray was on it d-ray
yeah
that's older though right look is that
charlemagne the guy with the bed down in
the hat
back there like next to uh like go to
the third picture
the star picture now when he has his
head on he's smiling yeah that one is
that charlemagne no it's not charlemagne
i'm sorry
yeah he's one of the originals wow yeah
they got adrian broner in there
they've had everyone they had everybody
did you ever would you ever do wild
enough
well you can't do it now i could do it
why not no
they're gonna try and figure out
something without nick cannon and
willing maybe
i don't know man it's gonna be so white
they're gonna have terry crews as those
well then
wow you're gonna do this dance here i
don't know what they're gonna do
all right all this right here jeffrey
toobin master
bruh yeah
he's suspender now right yeah he's he's
uh he's in
trouble new yorkers he got suspended for
jackie because he's doing a zoom call
and thought
thought he was off camera started
jacking off how crazy he's that
he had another tab open he was watching
porn
and apparently there's a lot like a lot
of important people on that call too you
couldn't wait
he was watching all the porn people on
that call no important to people
oh hold on
so two people who were on the call told
vice separately that the call was an
election stimulation featuring many of
the new yorkers biggest stars
jane meyer was playing establishment
republicans
evan was joe biden all right doesn't
matter does it matter does
it matter uh and jeffrey tubin playing
the courts there were also a handful of
other producers on a call from
new yorker um
[Music]
what's trying to tell you man uh so here
it goes noted that it was unclear how
much
each person saw but both said they saw
two and jerking off
he said jerking the two sources
described a joke in the
election simulation when there was
strategy session democrats was one of
the respective break rooms for about 10
minutes
at this point they said it seemed like
tuban was on a second video caller
said that when the groups returned from
their break rooms toobin
lowered the camera the people on the
call said they could see
tuban touching his penis tube and then
left the call moments later he called
back to unaware of his colleagues had
been able to see
damn what i want to know like what's up
sorry i lost service yeah everybody good
yeah sorry about that i'm back
i want to know who's the [ __ ] on the
call i just wanted to say it but didn't
say
i can't believe he was that horny that
he couldn't wait tubing you're so
relaxed now like
chill bruh but he has a few allegations
against them
two that's probably something that
turned him on too though right like he
has all these people on the call yeah
there's like probably got like a rug
he has a long line of uh sexual
allegations
but then even oj because he went after
o.j
hello twitter world let's go oh
james his voice is just so funny these
days it is funny
damn
his comparison with someone all the way
in the 80s like was [ __ ]
go hard on oj or something yeah [ __ ]
yeah
after him when all that's when you know
oj was going through his stuff oh [ __ ]
youtube was known for going after people
that's why no no like
people are glad this is happening to him
oh [ __ ] but why did he get suspended
and not fired again oh yeah so not fire
[ __ ] i don't know yeah
it's like it's an embarrassing thing
mostly i guess i mean
you can't cancel a guy for i mean he i
guess he's in his
listen i don't think i i don't believe
in cancer culture and
all this [ __ ] so it's like you're
getting like suspended because why would
they find him
he's still good at his job he did on
purpose whether you agree with him or
not
like it was an act it was an honest
mistake does everyone on that call
not masturbate are we gonna pretend no
one else jacks off
and homeboy was jacking off he thought
they were taking a ten minute break
and he was in his home yeah he thought
the camera's off jacking off so you're
gonna fire him over what
for being a horn dog for being a dumbass
i guess we're gonna die man
his problem is there's other sexual
allegations this is just
piles on top of it oh once they and then
once they get you they just keep like
piling that [ __ ]
especially if you're known for going
after people like oj and other other
you know people oh these people like
people maya dance back around what are
you saying
goes around comes around man i don't
know that's why i don't i don't really
gossip like that though
but again again i i don't like him i you
know i think
this is my first time ever hearing them
people out there
i mean people at the new york new yorker
that you know
they're so political and they want to
[ __ ] on trump and do all this stuff
so it's like i don't agree with him but
i don't think he should lose his job
he is good at what he does you know
what does he do he's a writer for a new
yorker he's like a reporter oh he's a
writer yeah reporter
writer for the new yorker well he's been
doing it for years years
i mean big time guy over there new york
you don't want to retire
i don't know what the [ __ ] he's gonna do
it's a good time he wants to jack off
that's what he wants to do yeah once
yeah why don't you retire have a little
jack off
well it's got what's like you know the
media with the biden story
because you we don't have it on here i'm
sure current event unless jay sent it
but
so you know twitter and facebook this is
a huge issue again
it's not red or this isn't a red or blue
issue this is an issue of free speech
so when the biden news came out that
they had
that laptop and hunter bite and all this
[ __ ] and there's you know collusion with
russia and ukraine and china
illegal [ __ ] we don't you don't want any
politicians being on that it's not good
for the for the nation when that came
out and news broke
people posted it facebook and uh twitter
took it down
twitter world twitterworld took it all
down because they're pro
biden they hate trump what but they're a
private
company right so they're kind of allowed
to do it but you got to realize like
this is what
north korea does this is what china does
it's not a democracy at this point yeah
it's not free it's free speech but you
allow all this other
hatred stuff or trump and his collusion
his stuff
his dealings with russia where there's
no evidence of that you let all that
other [ __ ] go away
you let all that ride you let all this
weird [ __ ] ride but then this
which was influenced the the political
race you
pull that like now you're [ __ ] with
free speech
this should be a way bigger deal than it
is yeah so when when
pretty sure trump is going to bring it
up tomorrow and a lot of people like we
didn't know about this
you didn't know about what well like by
my son yeah that's insane so
so so when he brings but i didn't know
people were talking [ __ ] to trump either
so keep going yeah but when he brings it
up tomorrow
a lot of people will be like yo what is
he talking about they're not though
because here's the thing
so twitter i love this twitter and
facebook i would have loved it if it had
been if this news about
trump and they tried suppressing
information and got out
because it again you're taking away free
speech man like this is what makes
america so
like are we in north korea are we in
china this is what we're going to do
we're not going to let facts out so by
them suppressing it
news started to travel so then people go
oh [ __ ] and they look up the story so
they found out
by them doing that the new york post who
originally released the
the the laptop information on hunter
biden
new new york post found out that the
information actually doubled
in viewership oh because the secret name
yeah because the people like wait what
were they trying to hide so
people searched for it so it actually
made the story even bigger so it's
better
it's better for trump that way yeah
yeah all right i wasn't trying to hide
the world for my baby i was trying to
hide the baby from my world okay
that's what drake's right okay all right
but how crazy did they impeach trump
because they thought he had dealings
with
china and it came out they were doing it
the whole time
we have evidence that biden was doing it
so what you impeach trump for bite it
was
how old is his son is it something like
in his 20s or something no he's like
oh he's in his 40s yeah he's like i
imagine a kid in his [ __ ] twenties he
did his dad giving him a shot dude
oh [ __ ] i didn't know it was dad 78 dude
complete [ __ ] i did not know that you
could just tell he'd do him
i was literally thinking of a person in
their 20s
this was this one i this my favorite
part about they released the tweets
this dude's so [ __ ] stupid because he
had to kind of hide it that
he was getting money from china ukraine
and given to his dad because he would
say i'll introduce
my dad if you give me this amount of
money you're not allowed to do that
so they he would go hey we got whatever
100 million from china
give 10 give 10 million to the big man
like we wouldn't figure out you're
talking about your dad oh the big man
i love it i love it so that's
a weird ass code name yeah big man
hey big man hey big man you think you're
tough big man yeah
you don't know get the money to my baby
now cnn's doing what trump did and goes
oh this is fake news
oh it's fake news oh
bro you know we call that circle of life
oh
circle you always come back what goes
around yeah i just i didn't get how
biden can go on the stand tomorrow and
debate
when if you're trump you just nail this
home like i bet you he gets
corona or yeah i don't know or it backs
out and you just say it's it's fake
he'll just say it's fake i'm sure
like there's no real evidence or
something like that but here here's how
you know it's not fake too because if
you go through the text which i did
like look at you you go deep i love it
i think it's so interesting but the uh
like you can tell biden's a good dad
because like his son's d like there's a
there's a portion of those texts where
the son's in rehab
and his son gives him this long list
like they say i'm gonna be the reason
why you don't become president because
i'm such a [ __ ] up in my dark history
blah blah
and biden joe biden god bless him goes
don't worry about any of that son focus
on your cover right now love you
dad oh and then there's a text hey good
morning son hope
recovery is going well thinking of you
love you debt your dad
so it's like [ __ ] dude he typed his
people typed it
uh who knows he's so old you know yeah
because he was like he probably didn't
know yeah i was about to say right
he has no idea who's texting he takes
like the old lady here
he has no idea yeah yeah also um
uh did you hear about the uh the police
force
uh they're like so the guys the carriers
the news oh this like oh here we go
it's a lot of pressure right now yeah
all right we watched we watched the race
you better go because i have to pee so
bad
hold on like so the ballasts are being
corrupt like they're
like the male imbalance the male
imbalance right okay so
the uh come on there's a lot of pressure
so dude
political news break all right look wait
wait oh
so wait wait it is tough i don't know
okay all right look so the mail in
ballots
the melon ballast of frost right so that
so they what they're doing now
this guy uh luis luis uh he met in front
of you know
louise they met you know what i'm
talking about now get into it look so
look louise
uh uh damn it's a lot of pressure come
on i love you queen
all right look at it so luis he
testified he's like i'm no way
in in hell corrupting like people's
valleys to vote
right so what he did was there's alright
we'll stay out of it so what he did was
i'm gonna stay out of it
he literally like told the police force
don't like carry like don't guard the
mail carriers like let them
be on their own and they they go to
these dangerous dangerous neighbors
neighborhoods and by themselves with the
ballots to like delivery like
oh you want to turn in your vote mail so
they'll just jack them
right so so they'll jack their tape what
are you going to do with stolen votes
well because now you can't turn it in
because it turns in or you make them all
by the way exactly they were trying to
make money off you said the hood
no well no i'm just saying like when
they say dangerous neighborhoods they
talking about the
you know the ballet yeah yeah the people
who can make a difference
now okay um that's the difference yeah
okay so when this guy so now they had
this woman um i'm losing it baby
tim i need your help shannon i need your
help can you type in uh
louise louise yes
voting ballots yeah this is voting
battles yeah louise
like no no no no
yeah there it is morales there it is yes
sir that's him wait
wait hold olivia bolivia no no no no no
no no no no
no where do you find your current event
can you go to the right
type
that's a place voter fraud being
investigating saying louise
no that's just april never mind i
apologize
but i watched it rachel maddow yeah type
in rachel maddow
here we go let's see is that the hipster
traffic supporters
that was a month ago uh we was talking
about that last night
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait even the justin's that's
september we lost
all right yeah well yeah what was the
main show i mean so this lady
forget her name uh forget her name so
she literally married
mary mary so she brought attention a lot
of people were and she was like yo why
they're doing this and she is
just one old white woman in uh san
francisco she was like listen
they're trying to rig the election of
course but the fact that luis
remember him was important factor in the
story he went in front of a judge
and told them lied to their faces and he
just told the police to stand down
so people can give you your mail he
should be arrested
and i want to bring light to that
situation
you know the battle
[Music]
all right i don't know what the [ __ ] is
that
but people are there's there's
definitely no voter fraud
i'll do better next time i'm gonna do
better you better
know what you did
i didn't know what happened i had it i
it happens current events man
well you this is all you dude no no
right yeah
i we got the news report that mao pulled
up
rachel maddow what does it say usps
pulls uninformed police chewing golem
from protective patrols
wall street journal i guess i still
don't know what's going on
i have no idea
the police patrol for the news carriers
that's kept uh
carrying about the voting ball yeah
what else we got there you go okay so i
guess we're gonna start doing a few
grams of the week
oh i said i just said i got i got your
chappelle first one and i said the
article too
i didn't send you another no no not this
one this is uh
gram of the week they got a few of them
popped up again i saw bar stool
uh they did like one of their one minute
man episodes on britney spears
and i guess she won like a small battle
in her con
conservatoship conservatorship
concerning yeah with her dad
she had like a small uh win and she
ended up posting
more on social media there was one video
of her dancing in like this red bikini
because her dad owns like everything he
basically like owns her life
like her uh her right to like have more
children her right to marry
her right to go and now why does he own
it because when she was young
he she she signed over like these rights
she went all crazy shaved her head and
[ __ ]
that's when she that's when he took over
i think so because i think they like
basically forced her into rehab to get
better and he ended up with
basically like all this power over what
she can and can't do because she
is unstable but now he's controlling her
life
even though she is technically healthy
like he's putting her on
more medication telling her like she
can't have more children she can't marry
she can't do certain performances she
has to stay home all the time
she's not even in her 40s she's like
blocking her down she may be like
very early 40s she might be like close
to theo's age it must be really bad
though
it must have been really bad i wonder
where she's at mentally his uh
his her lawyer said that he had to
represent her because she's essentially
like a comatose patient
like she can't think for herself that's
what he was saying her lawyer
wow and there's like this weird
conspiracy where people are saying all
these videos
you only see her in her house yes or
like in the front of her house it's kind
of the same location if she's outdoors
but if she's like on a beach
or it's like one of these videos where
she's doing like a handstand
she's always wearing a mask and people
think it's someone else to make it seem
like she's out living her life
oh and she's okay because her dad has
control over her social media too
holy what so there's that and then
there's another video if you scroll up
like that horse people have been
commenting saying we know it's not you
britney
what and so there's this weird
conspiracy of like gosh this is
right or is this her dad posting because
that's just a lot she might be
bat [ __ ] crazy that's another thing she
might she might
she hasn't carried she has kids i think
she lives in calabasas there you go
you see yourself in britain they don't
think that's brittany
no because like you'll never see her
face in these types of videos
god damn if he's like it's somebody
blonde with a mask or
like the back of her oh
wow cause these type of posts started to
come out after
the news the post also sounds like an
older dude wrote it this was a great
experience i had look at all those
million emojis my horse was beautiful
well there's her face there though she
just showed you yeah
this could also be on her ranch too in
calabasas because that you know what
hawaii doesn't have those big timber
trees like that
oh look at him
yeah she might be bat [ __ ] crazy though
i don't know like the dad might be like
all right [ __ ] you want her yeah i
mean
i'm trying my best to keep things yeah i
signed the petition yeah
why are they weird i don't know
either way she's not doing well either
way i said we see her face so what are
you saying we
just like certain videos they make it
seem like but i said hey
why not give it another shot but while
i'm at it i just wanted to let you guys
know
the five most important things that you
need to bring when you go to the beach
hell yeah a towel
yes oil thank you a dog
and a hat yes i'm gonna go to my jacuzzi
now
so this is the example wow she makes
videos like this
she might be crazy i'm convinced now so
we don't know what's happening
because yeah who's around her for these
it's like that vin diesel [ __ ]
where's her friends she was she is she
allowed to have friends
all i know is that she has a boyfriend
she has a really hot boyfriend
is he young yes i figured that hmm she
looks
bad she crazy
no is that her boyfriend
shouts out look at me over there look at
terry crews you see me
this is gonna be you and brendan after
one month
look gary that's me and brandon look at
that look at that look at us
that bbm
damn that's cool 300 pound food
damn you could just tell he all he do is
gtd what's that
gym tan laundry oh you mean gto
yeah there it is you said gtd don't
worry about it let's just continue to
the next currency
this guy's killing it no no i'm just
messing up right now she got
i'm so upset that's it oh this is yours
brandon oh there's that new hummer now
that you guys give me electric
cars hummer uh how do i know is that
electric yeah it's electric
eevee it's supposed to compete with the
the bronco tesla and the tesla truck
yeah
do you like the way it looks i don't
that'd look hard i don't know if i like
it i haven't made hummers in a minute
right
uh-uh that looks hard bro what are you
talking about oh you used to have a
hummer
detroit build hummer ev with like the
front i don't really dig
[Music]
like a transformer car yeah yeah that
thing's sick looks like a zombie
apocalypse of a transformer
better car and what do you mean i don't
like cars you're a car guy
i don't have one yeah it doesn't mean
you can't be a car guy
i'd have a car as a kid but i enjoyed
cars uh you know what i like lowriders
those are probably like my favorite
what's your favorite lowrider
that 64 uh chevy and polymer oh what
color now what color
i mean any color i just like that
[ __ ] car uh i'll put a cotton candy
on there i got a homie uh out in arizona
louise he's got an el camino that he's
done up real good that'd be dope i know
i'm so sorry i mean i don't want to i'm
not a big lowrider guy but i know i can
appreciate them
you wouldn't i wouldn't know are you
serious no grown man
well you be a grown man oh man
i can't believe it yes you don't yes you
can that'd be fun
travis parker has some of the sweetest
old-school
you just gotta appreciate a classic
though yeah you got it well you said was
khalifa got a bad one
yeah he shows it on that like new
if anybody watch you got a dope ass
lowrider
i want to see that [ __ ] no wait wait no
he shows it on that cribs show that new
crib show he's on chris
they're still back but it's like a
different thing that they do
um
i don't know internet is very slow here
today
there's a new grip show on mtv it's not
on mtv it's not cribs it's like uh
my dream um oh [ __ ] 63.
yeah that's just 63. they show niger on
it
like i don't know what the actual thing
is called there's some
current event what's going on here for
everyone
go to youtube type in niger houston home
and you'll see what the show is called
i love it ever since i saw boys in the
hood yo
let me out that architectural digest
architectural digest
yes that's a good i like that youtube
channel yeah yeah i've never heard of it
they show just like celebrities homes um
they do from uh
celebrity homes they just they take them
on a tour it's really like really
outlandish like super expensive
what's that guy's name the from the from
with the drugs the meth the drugs the
medical breaking
bad breaking bad brian cranston uh no
guy that was with aaron paul
air ball his home is really dope he
lives in boise
oh here come the boise shout out
yeah tickets just went on sale i just
send that to you cat okay yeah
i'm saying this house is dope as [ __ ]
yeah
it's so woody this cat yeah it's a
cabinet it's like a noisy though it's
better
that feels homely though but it feels
like an airplane thanksgiving place yeah
oh we got dope air b for uh boise oh i
can't wait
oh is it like that yeah it looks pretty
like woody you know
yeah should probably want to see your
one real quick
yeah do your one yeah okay talk about it
i just didn't even read the damn article
i just
sent that to me oh there you go tyler
this is yours yeah
italian king star carol baskin comes out
as bisexual bam
yeah uh not i don't even watch that show
yet but i'm not
you haven't seen tiger king yet because
i heard so much about it from everybody
i was like
i'm with you on those type of training
the funniest part the funniest part
uh about that series is at the end when
the fbi
informant just finished snitching and
just drove
that's the funniest [ __ ] no
he just finished snitching and he was
like yo i just told z
yeah no sense but she coming out as
bisexual but she got a husband
oh does she i mean we could be bisexual
we just talked about that
we just talked about that earlier are
they going to add another person to
their relationship
i'm not i don't think she's saying like
she wants to be
in a relationship with two people she's
like i like men and i like women
is she trying to just say that to stay
relevant because some of these
celebrities do that
yeah they come out just to stay relevant
yeah what did she
oh yeah like demi lovato's ex-fiance
yeah he came out as gay
oh no no no i thought yeah it's a girl
uh no
uh that guy that she was like just
engaged to
talk about like two months max eldritch
or whatever yeah like they got together
during
uh the pandemic he was like blasting her
everywhere saying like he's super in
love
they got engaged a couple months into
being in a relationship
and she ended up dumping him because she
found out that it was all a publicity
stunt for him
and so she like dumbed him wants nothing
to do with him and he started like
staging weird things like he'll put
cryptic instagram posts out there he
went back to the beach where he proposed
and people there are like paparazzi
photos of him like crying on the beach
it was weird it was really weird he got
a girl but what
does this guy look like i don't think i
don't know if he's gay or not but
it's it's super weird now he has like a
girlfriend
and her lawyers are saying that like he
won't leave her alone like she's trying
to get
him to like not call her anything she
uh called off the engagement engagement
because she
like fan center like hey he's just
he's trying to come after anyone famous
and they went back to his old like
tweets
he was tweeting like with selena gomez
like trying to holler
because they were best friends yeah
being like oh i love you
like if i could just marry you my life
be complete like all the way and then he
used to say that demi lovato is ugly
compared to selena gomez
people like twitter accounts and stuff
like that that's crazy holla at me
this guy yeah that guy that's him that's
him
no it ain't not anymore that's not her
man
hmm i mean yeah
damn that's the dude she was rocking
with i would have never thought that i
know
i'm a david levita fan that she sung
that song sonny what is your commander
in
uh yeah what else you got
i got this right here um oh are we still
on instagram
yeah videos she's a bellator fighter
yeah she's wait she fights he's a
fighter fighter yeah really good fighter
oh really
taekwondo's are like background oh shoot
yeah yeah sure
she's and that's the picture you just
gonna lie i mean it's just
it's incredible her body do you want
something more wholesome now i just
wanna
i didn't know you don't like her no i
love her i'm just
just showing me she doesn't know i love
her she looks like like she would never
think she's a straight-up model she's so
funny does she have any fight videos on
there or anything no
um well there's one or her knocking
someone out yeah she's she's a beast
that's her
an ig model oh somebody was talking [ __ ]
oh somebody was talking [ __ ] and she
damn she had the peace of mind she has
to be the finest fighter yeah
i would have to say that's our man right
there i don't really know rachel
ostervich is bad too
yeah look at that look at that stump
ridiculous
it's like it's like it's crazy
it's unbelievable it's it's not fair
what else you got check this out
nature with chen love it he doesn't want
to make it
what's that we're just going to call
this segment how cool is that
how cool is that what's that it should
be like a that should be like a new soft
but honestly yeah what is this how cool
is this watch
it's a magpie a backpack's a bird it's
actually the national bird of korea
it'll swoop in here there's a trash on
someone's car truck
oh it looks like a truck boom
damn that's kind of hard i didn't know
that i thought
transfers they're like birding
tarantulas but boom
dude get me in here damn that's pretty
dope
don't don't they're fishing their fish
is that dope what's up birds
yeah that wasn't a regular bird though i
mean it's a regular it looks like a
regular like sparrow type
it's a little bit bigger but i don't
know that birds can see mice from
[ __ ]
all the way at the top yeah but remember
i wanted to get a neck tattoo
this is the bird i'm literally thinking
of getting this bird what's that i'm
gonna get the tarantula getting eaten
lunch all right so this is probably the
last current event
it's just uh i don't know who this
person is she must be some sort of like
political
celebrity on instagram or something like
that but she is talking about all the
different rules
for covid in california for the holidays
coming up it's a bunch of crap though
they tried they're trying to take away
christmas and thanksgiving yeah they
don't want to
get together nazi newsome was like you
can't have gatherings for
either holiday how many people are going
to put up with that
how long do you want to live like north
korea so
all right i'll go back to this one in a
bit but um
this is adam carolla's response to it
the very last part of what he says
he's awesome my tip is
everyone in california should just
invite every family member
and every friend over their home sit in
their living room
and have a turkey and if there's a knock
on the door and the authorities want to
know what you're doing
tell them you're having a blm route
you're allowed to do that yeah damn and
now
he used to be a boxer yeah adam carroll
yeah yeah we used to talk sir carpenter
yeah he had him he had a movie about uh
him yeah yeah yeah
that's a pretty funny movie he's a dope
i think he's gonna happen oh yeah
now he really did he comes back into
boxing or something he was done for a
while and
yeah that's how he met uh jimmy kimmel
yeah that's a great story
he was his trainer that's how he met
jimmy kim yeah jimmy kimmel was on
you know he was on the big radio station
out here in l.a and he goes hey i'm
looking we're going to do a charity
boxing match i need a trainer
and adam carly got on i was like i'll
train you and then him and jimmy got
together they didn't know each other got
together and he's like did your funny
come on the show
and that's how oh that's so great he's
such a cool guy
he's such a cool guy his stand up is
good he's great i performed with him at
the
hollywood prize no laugh yeah he's great
yeah we shot him back in here we just
had we had him up right when corona hit
yeah he was
awesome though he's so dope yeah yeah
100 he's so cool
1 percent it's like insightful
conversations with him
oh dude he loves cars doesn't he oh yeah
yeah he's huge
he's got any hondas for sale that's all
i'm looking for
uh someone i always forget to get get
the name of the person that tagged me
keith so this is just like they're
complete opposites i don't know how
legit this video is
is either but i'll let you watch it
so that little guy has a huge truck and
that big-ass dude
is in a smart car
oh you know this is fake you know that
right i kind of feel like it is this
that's
the baby's bodyguard the baby's
bodyguard yeah
so he's making a video he's making video
yeah
they just making yeah pretty sure i
don't know all right go
to the baby's bodyguard that's him yeah
i'll look it up after this
oh damn dude's getting back out but it
looks like it could be a youtube video
you know
there you go big guy
hello that's pretty much it weird
it's weird i don't i don't think that's
real no he would have beat his ass yeah
yeah he's too friendly with him too
friendly he he makes funny videos sure
he makes funny videos okay it's got to
be him then i don't think that's him
i think one guy's white and then one's
black
damn it i promise you go to his
instagram i'm not that i'm not fumbled
in the background
that that's a white guy for god's sakes
it's okay that's not that's
that dude the big guy is not the one oh
white dude
no he's not how does it work
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't tell
that's a white guy voice that's a white
dude look at his legs
oh that's a good point the legs all
right so so he has a tattoo on his leg
right
i can't tell another side side you can't
tell they're both this arm looks like
they're both okay now ran that'd be to
say that's the baby's bodyguard
all right can we go to his page he makes
a lot of fun he makes a lot of funny
videos
uh instagram what's his name what's his
name
yeah kane they're right there look at
all these funny videos you make
oh [ __ ] that is him right there no don't
worry don't worry about it don't worry
about it i don't worry about it
read it i know i was on board
i apologize what if he was what is a big
dude with chats
but he makes fun of me yeah look at his
legs his legs are too tight yeah they're
way too tattered
he's also black why
[ __ ]
that lady is having a good time i
wouldn't say this is a funny profile
malik yeah no he makes fun of me he's a
big dude
who keeps posting pictures of himself
wait wait what i'm saying hold on
there's nothing funny on him yeah he's
not doing anything funny
okay that's a funny you gotta go to his
youtube he makes funny videos this is
what he does
you know any videos he has like this he
probably don't post them but he's tagged
and all that's a funny video what i'm
just saying like stuff like that he does
skits and that's fake you know that's
fake
yeah pranks and stuff okay the word
funny let's okay i was heavy on that
he does skits instagram screaming you're
having a rough day it's fine
yeah it happens i'm so mad i botched
that damn got it
i think that's it news report all right
man uh tickets for boise just went on
still today
refresh that from your channel you'll
see boise on there for god's sakes
yes sir there it is boise december 5th
one show right now we want to add
another so buy them [ __ ] tickets
boise idaho first time going there boise
idaho one night only one
theater uh that's december 5th tickets
just went on sale
no idea what it's going to be like out
there phoenix november 5th through the
7th
nashville november 19th to 21st boise
december
5th get your ticks now tfatkay.com i got
dates too
what do you got i got a timpy improv uh
what the hell is it november 27th
through the 29th those tickets
are on sale so yeah thanksgiving weekend
it'll be fun
be home be in the hometown for
thanksgiving
calm and then uh merch i got merch now
which you also find on the
site as well just hit that love is tight
love is
you got it love is tight baby is that it
kids that's it
all right we're out all right big boy
merge bike big boy bike club merch